My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我叫雅娜（Yana），是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。通往这一职业的道路竟然有这么多，而且没有一条完美的必经之路，这让我感到非常惊讶。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，让我觉得“不，我并没有做错”，从而减轻了我的心理压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些忐忑，我绝对推荐你看这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. So you want to become a CBT therapist but don't know where to start. From the training routes to the reality of the job, this episode gives you the lowdown on how to qualify, what to expect and what it's really like working as a CBT therapist in the UK. If you're exploring psychology career options or mapping your next steps, don't miss this. I'm chatting with Sahana, a qualified CBT therapist, and I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. If you enjoy the content, please do like and subscribe for more to help support you in your psychology and mental health journey.
但相信我，一旦你开始阅读，就绝对舍不得放下。如果你想成为一名认知行为疗法（CBT）治疗师，却又不知道从何开始，那么本期节目将为你提供详尽的信息：从培训途径到工作现实，告诉你如何获得资质、该期待什么，以及在英国作为一名CBT治疗师工作究竟是怎样的体验。如果你正在探索心理学职业选项或规划下一步，千万不要错过。今天我和合格的CBT治疗师萨哈娜（Sahana）一起聊天，我是合格的临床心理学家玛丽安（Marian）博士。如果你喜欢这期内容，请点赞并订阅，以获取更多支持你在心理学和心理健康之路上前行的内容。
Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I'm joined here by my guest today, Sahana, who is a qualified CBT therapist. Hi, hi, Sahana. Hello, hello, thank you for having me. Thank you for being here for our second episode, because we've already done one episode, which people can catch up about kind of CBT from a potential service user's angle, because there's someone who might want to kind of find out what CBT is and whether it be a good fit for them therapeutically. So please do watch that one if you haven't already.
嗨，欢迎收看“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是合格的临床心理学家玛丽安博士，今天和我一起做客的嘉宾是萨哈娜，她是一位合格的CBT治疗师。嗨，萨哈娜。你好，你好，谢谢邀请我来。谢谢你来参加我们的第二期节目，因为我们已经制作了一期节目，人们可以从潜在服务使用者的角度来了解CBT的相关内容，因为有些人可能想了解什么是CBT，以及它是否适合他们的心理治疗。如果你还没看过那一期，请务必观看。
And there'll be a link to that at the end of this episode. But today we're thinking about CBT as a career option, as a career move. Could you tell us a kind of a brief overview of how you came to be a CBT therapist please yeah so I finished my BSE in applied clinical psychology that was in 2018 then I went on to do my PwP work so I qualified as a PWP did that for a couple of years and by the two-year mark I started noticing this is around 2020 that there's a bit of a gap in knowledge rather so I was finding that you know I'm assessing for PTA but I'm going to CBT therapists and getting advice from them and had to assess them.
本期节目结束时会提供该节目的链接。但今天我们要把CBT作为一种职业选择、一种职业转型来思考。请简要概述一下你是如何成为一名CBT治疗师的，好吗？好的，我在2018年完成了应用临床心理学的理学学士学位，接着我从事了心理健康从业者（PWP）的工作。因此，我获得了PWP资质并干了几年。到了第二年左右，也就是2020年左右，我开始注意到知识上存在一些差距。我发现自己在评估创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）时，需要去找CBT治疗师向他们征求建议，并对患者进行评估。
So just to bridge the gap, I felt like it was a natural progression to then go for the CBT training. Amazing. So what did that look like? Was it provided for you kind of via the NHS through your workplace? What was the what was the course called and how did it all happen? In terms of how I went about getting that role, I actually applied on the NHS website. So it would be posted as a trainee CBT role. I applied for it. To prepare for the interview, you need to have something called a KSA portfolio.
因此，为了弥补这一差距，我觉得参加CBT培训是一个很自然的进阶过程。太棒了。那么，这个过程是怎样的？它是通过NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）由你的工作单位为你提供的吗？那个课程叫什么名字，这一切是如何发生的？关于我是如何获得那个职位的，我其实是在NHS网站上申请的。它当时是以CBT实习生职位发布的。我申请了。为了准备面试，你需要准备一份叫做KSA的作品集。
So that stands for knowledge, skills and abilities portfolio. It's a really big portfolio where it asks you about your knowledge as a practitioner. So if you're not part of the core professions, you need to sort of look a bit more about what do you do within your current field? It also looks at your skills, so things like. like basic principles, like collaboration, working together. So as we know, NHS is very multidisciplinary. Have you got experience of that, working together in teens?
KSA代表知识、技能和能力作品集（Knowledge, Skills and Abilities portfolio）。这是一个非常大的作品集，它会考察你作为一名从业者的知识。所以，如果你不属于核心专业人员，你需要花更多时间去审视你在当前领域中究竟做了什么。它还会考察你的技能，比如基本原则，像合作、共同工作。众所周知，NHS是一个高度跨学科的机构。你是否有这方面的经验，是否具备在团队中共同工作的经验？
And then obviously your attitudes as well. What are your motivations for applying? What have you got to bring to the table personally? And how does that translate professionally? And once that's submitted and they've had a look at it, then you get onto the training after you do some interviews. So it's quite a bit of a process, but it can be done if you kind of methodically put that work in. Okay, amazing.
显然还有你的态度。你申请的动机是什么？你能为团队带来什么个人贡献？这在职业上是如何体现的？一旦提交作品集并通过审核，在经过一些面试后，你就可以参加培训了。所以这确实是一个不小的流程，但如果你有条不紊地去完成这些工作，这是完全可以做到的。好的，太棒了。
Before I respond properly to what you just said, you gave me some really interesting information there that actually you did an undergraduate psychology degree that also gave you a qualification because that's really unusual. I wish I'd done that when I did my psych undergrad. So what's funny is this was a decade ago. So psychology was still kind of the culture was, at least in my experience, it's like you're not going to get a professional role in psychology. You're going to sort of end up doing something else that's different to psychology. But this, so I was very mindful about that. So this specific degree that I did, it actually attached the PWP training.
在我正式回应你刚才的话之前，你刚刚提供了一些非常有趣的信息：你读本科时学的是心理学，并且这个学位还直接赋予了你从业资质，这真的非常罕见。我真希望我读心理学本科时也能这样。有趣的是，这已经是十年前的事了。当时的文化是——至少以我的经验来看——人们会觉得“你在心理学领域是找不到专业工作的，你最后肯定会去从事其他与心理学不同的工作”。因此，我对这一点非常在意。我所读的这个特定学位，实际上将PWP培训包含在内了。
So I did my PW training on my dissertation in my third year. And I actually was a qualified PDVP ready to go off to the big world and work at low intensity. Amazing. Thank you. I didn't even know that was possible. So yeah, for anyone that's kind of thinking about their psychology career, if you haven't yet done your psych degree, there are options that can make you actually qualify to sit with clients and do work at the point that you graduate. So you said that it's a funded role. Does that mean they pay you or does that just mean that they pay your fees or is it a little bit of both? Both. So they would pay you for your training and they will also pay you salary. So you'd be working at band six. Some services do band five. So yeah, it's a year worth of training and 44 weeks of teaching. So a week would be up of two days of training and three days of placement. So it sounds like maybe you are employed by an NHS trust, but you're almost seconded to a university to do the learning aspects? Yeah. Yeah. So you would have a tutor to go through like the portfolio and the essays and things like that.
所以我在第三学期做毕业论文时就完成了PWP培训。我实际上已经是一个合格的PWP，随时准备步入大社会，从事低强度干预工作了。太棒了，谢谢。我甚至都不知道这还是可能的。所以，对于任何正在考虑自己心理学职业生涯的人来说，如果你还没读心理学学位，其实有一些选项可以让你在毕业时就具备面对客户并开展工作的资质。你刚才说这是一个有资助的职位，这意味着他们会付薪水给你，还是仅仅意味着他们为你支付学费，或者两者兼有？两者兼有。他们会为你的培训付费，同时也会支付你薪水。所以你的薪级会是第六级（band six）。有些服务机构是第五级（band seven/five）。所以是的，这是一年的培训，包括44周的教学。一周通常包括两天培训和三天实习。听起来你可能是被某个NHS信托基金（NHS Trust）雇佣的，但你几乎是被借调到一所大学去学习理论知识部分？对，是的。所以你会有一位导师，带你过一遍作品集、论文之类的事情。
and teach you the materials. They'll also be, you know, in my experience, there would be sort of pioneers in like the models like Sokoskies and Clark and David Ville. They'll come in and do master classes, so that way you kind of really get to the grips of the models, see how they kind of work and how to kind of do an intervention with that specific disorder.
并向你传授相关材料。据我所遇，还会邀请一些领域内的先驱人物，比如萨尔科斯基（Salkovskis）、克拉克（Clark）和戴维·克拉克（David Clark）之类的大咖。他们会来开展大师班，这样你就能真正掌握这些模型，了解它们是如何运作的，以及如何针对特定障碍进行干预。
But then you'd be working at a service and you'd be getting paid. Yeah, and I learnt my CBT when I was a trainee clinical psychologist. And actually, I've chosen this necklace very carefully today because this was the necklace that my placement supervisor gave me at the end of placement one. And I really, really liked working with her. And neither she nor the guy that supervised my CBT cases are with us in this world anymore. And so I thought, let's pay homage to both of those by wearing that necklace. It makes for a bit emotional even to think about it. But, you know, this is our lives, isn't it? When you're learning these skills, this is your life, you are trainee, but it's still
但同时你会在某个医疗机构工作并获得薪水。是的，我是在作为临床心理学实习生时学习CBT的。说实话，我今天非常仔细地挑选了这条项链，因为这是我的第一阶段实习督导在实习结束时送给我的项链。我非常非常喜欢和她一起工作。无论是她，还是督导我CBT案例的那位男士，如今都不在这个世界上。因此我想通过戴着这条项链，向他们两位致敬。仅仅想到这一点，都会让我觉得有点情绪激动。但是，这就是我们的生活，不是吗？当你正在学习这些技能时，这就是你的生活，你虽然是实习生，但它依然是
your real life. You'll still form real meaningful connections with the people you work with. And I still remember Brett, when he was teaching me CBT on placement, he'd be like, okay, so we've got to think about what this tells the person about their beliefs of themselves, the world and others. And even now, even though that was 2008 that he first taught me that, I still, is. 2025 think about you know myself the world and others and so you know you can carry these people that have taught you these skills and remember them fondly even even as you progress in your career so total aside but yeah what you said about your supervisor really kind of connected with me yeah I think that's a whole
你真实的生活。你仍会与你共事的人建立真实而有意义的联系。我还记得布雷特（Brett）在实习期间教我CBT时，他说：“好吧，我们要思考这向当事人传达了关于他们对自我、对世界以及对他人的什么信念。”即便到现在——尽管他第一次教我这些已经是2008年的事了——我依然会在2025年思考自我、世界和他人。所以，你可以带着这些曾教导你这些技能的人前行，并怀着深情记住他们，甚至随着职业生涯的推进也是如此。完全是题外话，但你刚才说的话，关于你的督导的那部分，真的深深触动了我。是的，我觉得这正是
mark of a good supervisor though when they can kind of imprint and embed the philosophies that they're kind of taught they then pass on to you absolutely I think your supervisors are going to be the bedrock so you'll get two supervisors so one through the university and the other through your service and the structure would look quite different from each other so in my service supervision it was one to one and it felt more personal and really that safety net and the bond in terms of being able to work through my imposter syndrome which we'll get into a little bit more detail but it definitely is a very
一个好督导的标志：当他们能够将自己所学的哲学理念灌输和嵌入其中，然后再传递给你时。绝对如此。我认为你的督导将是你职业生涯的基石。你会拥有两位督导：一位通过大学，另一位通过你的工作机构。两者的结构大不相同。在我的工作机构中，督导是一对一的，感觉更具个人色彩，真正成了一个安全网和纽带，能够帮助我克服“冒名顶替综合征”——我们稍后会更详细地探讨这一点。但这绝对是一个充满
time isn't it where you're feeling a bit rocky and you're needing that support so that there's the one-to-one service supervision but then there's also group supervision which again is is safe but it's quite different in the dynamic so there's three probably up to three people and you'd show recordings of your sessions so it can be quite exposing especially when you're learning to do a certain therapy and you're like still unsure about how you how would you be as a clinician you know there's people coming from different backgrounds. So I came from a PWP background. So the biggest shot for me in group supervision was why are people just not going fast enough? You know, usually you just cut to the chase. But I felt CBT was a bit more like you need to be more exploratory, socratic dialogue. That's a bit more
动荡的时期，不是吗？你会觉得自己有点飘摇，需要这种支持。因此，既有一对一的工作机构督导，也有小组督导。小组督导同样是安全的，但动态截然不同。小组里大约有三个人，你需要展示你的会话录音。这可能会让人感觉相当暴露，特别是当你还在学习如何进行某种治疗，并且对“作为一个临床医生，我究竟会表现成什么样”仍感到不确定时，身边却坐着来自不同背景的人。我拥有PWP背景。因此，在小组督导中对我的最大冲击是：“为什么大家不能走快一点？”通常你会直奔主题。但我觉得CBT更需要你去进行更多的探索，运用苏格拉底式对话。这种方法更为
prominent. And that's something I struggled with, which group supervision kind of really pull that out of me throughout my year. And I was able to learn from my other colleagues as well, kind of how did they go about, oh, I really like that. I think I'm going to see how I get on with that and then show my colleagues and you know my supervisor how how it played out so it's showing recordings is definitely part of the process so just just a heads up about that yeah but also know that that that feels awful for all of us so I've been on screens now regularly since 2020 maybe 2019 actually I am well aware of the things I do on screen and I'm well aware of how I sound and how I look. I'm all right with all of them now.
突出。而这正是我所挣扎的地方，整个一年下来，小组督导确实把这一点从我身上激发了出来。我也能够向其他同事学习：噢，我觉得那个方法真不错，我要看看自己能不能用好它，然后再向同事和督导展示效果如何。所以展示录音绝对是整个过程的一部分，提前给大家打个预防针。是的，但也要知道，对于我们所有人来说，这感觉都很糟糕。自2020年——也许是2019年——以来，我一直频繁出现在屏幕上，我很清楚自己在屏幕上做的事情，也很清楚自己的声音和外表。现在我对所有这些都释怀了。
Like I've seen it so much that like I'm just like, yeah, that's just how I am. So it is painful. None of us really love it unless you do it all day, every day like I do and you get used to it. You kind of, as we spoke about in the last episode, you habituate. Like there's no more, you know, I know what I sound like I know there's no more surprises coming. It is a really important part of of growth and of kind of 360 degree feedback. And, and even just honing in like, oh, I didn't know I did that. Or actually, when I think I've got a listening face, I look really bored. It's like, you know, if we're using audio recordings, obviously you don't necessarily get that. But if we're using audio and video, you get that feedback. But I think with the audio recordings,
看得多了，我就会想：“好吧，我就是这样的人。”所以这确实很痛苦。没有人真正喜欢它，除非你像我一样日复一日地整天这么做，然后就习惯了。正如我们在上一期节目中所讨论的那样，你会产生习惯化。不会再有……我清楚自己的声音听起来怎样，我知道不会再有突如其来的惊吓了。这是成长和360度全方位反馈中非常重要的一部分。甚至仅仅是去审视、注意到：“哦，我原来不知道自己会那样做”；或者“其实当我以为自己摆出倾听的表情时，我看起来真的很无聊”。你知道的，如果我们使用音频录音，你未必能注意到这些；但如果我们同时使用音频和视频，你就能得到这种反馈。不过我认为通过音频录音，
it's also really useful to think about actually when I said that, I think I spoke too soon. Perhaps I should have given it a minute. Like, you know, we can learn so much. And it is uncomfortable, but it's so useful. And I hope that you're in a situation. whoever's watching this, that it feels safe to have that growth. Yeah. No, I definitely don't want to put anybody off of having recorded, albeit very uncomfortable. And this was at the height of my social anxiety. So during my training, it was like, oh my God, not only am I going to have to present to my client as a trainee, but also then I'm going to show these videos to a group. But what I found really helpful, and that year I truly, I
思考“当我那样说的时候，我觉得自己话说得太早了，也许我本该再等上一分钟”也非常有用。我们可以从中学习到很多东西。这虽然让人感到不舒服，但却非常有价值。我希望无论谁在看这个节目，你都能身处一个让你觉得能够安全成长的环境中。是的，我绝对不想打消任何人进行录音的念头，尽管这确实让人感到很不舒服。当时正处于我的社交焦虑最严重的时候。在培训期间，我心想：“天哪，不仅我得作为实习生在客户面前表现，然后我还得把这些视频展示给一个小组成员看。”但我发现非常有帮助、并且在那一年我真正相信CBT对我有帮助的一点，是大量的自我练习。培训中有一个环节，你可以在作品集里反思你在实践中实际学到的技术，并将其应用到你自己身上。这是一段非常有回报的经历。正如你所说，让自己置身于这样的情境中，实际上就是在践行你所输出的东西。如果你自己都不知道你在兜售什么，那你……你知道我的意思吗？所以我认为这样做不仅能加深你的同理心，还能加深你作为临床医生的经验。因此，确实有相应的机制来帮助应对这种压力。这是一个可以理解的现实，甚至可以说，录音会话令人望而生畏。
believe CBD kind of helped me was a lot of self-practice. So there's a part of the training where in the portfolio you can reflect on the techniques that you actually learn on the go and apply it to yourself. And it was such a rewarding experience. And like you said, putting yourself in situations like that, you're kind of almost practicing what you kind of put out there, really, you know, if you don't know what you're selling, then, you know, what you, do you know what I mean? So I think it really deepens your empathy, but also your experience as a clinician as well to do that. So there's definitely things in place to help manage that. And it's an understandable fact, I want to even say, that recorded sessions are daunting.
没有人喜欢它们。他们也知道这一点，并在设立督导空间时就已经考虑到了这一点。所以他们会在整个过程中支持你。好的，太棒了。所以你的培训期是一年。其中有作业吗？有考试吗？你知道，你是否必须通过某些关键要素才能走到获得资质的终点？是的，有的。我们需要——好吧，当时是五年前的事了，顺便说一下，不过目前的结构仍然类似。你需要看八个客户，为他们提供一个完整的治疗疗程，并且你需要做反思。简而言之，要记录治疗档案和一个作品集。其中一个案例必须是PTSD，另一个是抑郁症。除此之外，你需要提交三份录音，
Nobody likes them. And they kind of know that and they set up the supervision space knowing that. So they will support you through that. Okay, amazing. So your training was a year. Are there are there assignments, are there exams, you know, do you have to pass certain, you know, key elements to get to the kind of qualification end point? Yes, so there are, we need to see, well, at the time, this is five years ago, by the way. So, but it's still similar to this structure. You see eight clients that you need to have a full course of treatment and you need to have a reflect. treatment record a portfolio in a nutshell one of them has to be PTSD and another for depression and on top of that you need to submit three tapes
并且必须使用名为CTSR的评分系统通过考核。所以如果你有兴趣追求CBT培训，一定要了解一下这个系统，因为他们会用它来给你的录音评分。除此之外，还有三篇论文。他们会提供许多问题供你选择，你需要挑选题目然后完成三篇不同的论文。我提到过案例报告吗？你还需要针对某个特定的客户（当然是匿名的）撰写案例报告，反思治疗过程、经验，以及支持你所做出的选择、你所采取的临床选择的证据。
which you need to pass using a marking system called CTSR and so definitely have a look at that if you're interested in pursuing CBT training because that's what they'll use to mark your tapes and then on top of that three essays which they all provide kind of of I think numerous questions, you should pick the question and then you do the essay, three different essays. Did I mention the case reports as well? There's case reports that you need to do on a specific client, obviously anonymised, reflecting on the process, the experience, but also the evidence supporting your choices, the clinical choices that you've made.
太棒了，谢谢。你身边有一群同期的同学吗？你们是一起经历这一切的吗？希望你能有……我知道，类似于什么？学习小组，或者甚至是一个跟你很合得来、你可以在需要时寻求支持的人。当然有。我们当时大约有20到25名同学组成的同期群体。在疫情期间，课程是远程进行的，但他们确实试图通过举办午餐聚会之类的方式来培养这种同事情谊。不过，我个人和与我在同一个医疗机构的实习生同行们建立起了非常紧密的联系。我们建了一个群聊，大家互相支持。还有我的小组督导以及那个小组动态里的同行们，我们也互相支持，
Amazing, thank you. And have you got a cohort around you? Are you all going this through this together so that hopefully you've got, I know, like what's that? groups or kind of even a person that you got on really well that you can kind of you know lean on for support definitely um so we there was a cohort of about um 20 of us 25 of us i'm going to say at the time during the pandemic it was remote but they did try to kind of foster that sense of camaraderie i guess by doing like lunch get-togethers but i personally grew really close with my trainee like my peers rather who were in the same services me so we had a group chat and we were leaning on each other and also my group supervision and the peers in that dynamic as well we leaned
互相给予反馈。老实说，就是互相支持，因为我们深知这种感受。当我们看到某段录音时会说：“你做得真好，我真的很喜欢那个部分，我要把它学过来，这周我也要试一试。”或者如果遇到什么事情，大家会说：“哦，也许……你知道吗？我也那样做过，我完全理解。这是经历的一部分，也是学习和成长的一部分。”所以你的周围绝对充满了支持。你还有课程导师。因此，如果你对提交作业感到担忧，或者不知道该写些什么、不清楚内容是什么，你可以跟你的课程导师谈谈，向他们寻求帮助。我以前就这么做过。当我不太确定时，他们给予了极大的支持。当然，
on each other as well kind of giving each other feedback um honestly just supporting each other you know we know just how it feels so when we see that take we're like you did really well i really like that bit i'm going to take that from me and i'm going to try it this week and yeah or if something's like oh maybe you know i do that too i completely get it it's part of the experience, it's part of learning and growing. So there's definitely support all around you. You've got your tutors as well. So if you are concerned about submissions or not knowing what do I write, you know, the content, you can speak to your course tutor, reach out to them. I've done it before. When I wasn't too sure and they were so supportive, but obviously
你的医疗机构也会支持你，因为你毕竟是个实习生。他们不会指望你表现得像一个经验丰富的合格CBT从业者。没关系，你可以犯错，这一切都会在一个安全、受控的督导环境中进行。这太重要了。那么具体是如何安排的呢？如果有人全职工作，即全时工作当量（WTE）、每周工作五天，那么其中几天是培训，几天是实习？这具体是怎样的？通常会有两天用于听讲座和在大学上课，也就是两个教学日。然后会有三天实习。实习期间大约需要看四位
you've got your service as well, supporting you through the same, no, you're a trainee. They're not going to expect you to be like a qualified CBT practitioner. It's okay. You can make mistakes. and it will be done in a safe space within a control, like supervision setting. So important. And how does this work? If someone's working full-time, whole-time equivalent, five days, how many days are training, how many days are on placement? You know, what does that look like? So there would be two days on lectures and just with the university, to teaching days. And then there'll be three days of placement. So that would be seeing about four,
你也有你的服务支持，陪你经历这些。不，你是个实习生，他们不会期望你表现得像个合格的CBT执业治疗师。没关系，你可以犯错，而且这会在一个安全、受控的环境中进行，比如督导设置。这太重要了。这具体是怎么运作的呢？如果有人是全职工作，全职当量，五天的工作里，几天用于培训，几天用于实习？你知道，具体是什么样的？通常是两天上课，也就是在大学里接受两天教学。然后会有三天实习。这样的话，大概会接触到四位，
clients, about three to four clients per day. It might sound like a lot, but you'll build up over time with that. So you won't start from the get COVID, four clients a day. You'll build yourself up to that point. Amazing. Okay, so when you qualify, when you come up the other side, you're a band seven. Yeah. Yeah, it's quite impressive. And I think it's well worth it for lots of reasons, but yeah, you qualify as a band seven. And what would a typical week look like if someone was working in a full-time capacity, for example. Is there an expectation of how many face-to-face hours they would typically be doing in a week? So once you qualify, you would be expected to do face-to-face days. It really depends on the service. So if I was to speak
客户，每天大约三到四位客户。这听起来可能有点多，但你会随着时间的推移逐渐适应并增加工作量。所以你不会一上来就应对一天四个客户的情况。你会慢慢适应到那个程度。太棒了。好的，那么当你获得资质、完成培训后，你的薪级会达到第七级（band seven）。是的。是的，这相当令人印象深刻。而且我认为出于很多原因，这是非常值得的。总之，你取得资质后就是第七级。如果有人以全职身份工作，典型的一周会是怎样的？对于他们一周通常需要进行多少面对面的工作小时数，是否有什么预期？一旦你取得资质，你就会被期望进行面对面的工作。这实际上取决于医疗机构。如果以我自疫情以来的个人经验来讲，一切都变了，不是吗？所以我有一半的时间用于面对面的客户，而另一半时间则用于远程客户或小组客户。小组治疗也可以是面对面的，或者是远程的。所以目前我采取的是每周工作四天：两天线下，两天远程。在这四天里，你通常会进行多少小时的干预？如果按正常的工作时间来算，一天大约会接待四个客户，也就是每天四次接触。太棒了。这类似于我在NHS工作时的情景，当时我力求达到50%的面对面时间，或者略高一点。我一边说一边在想，其实有些人可能会选择成为CBT治疗师。在我曾经工作过的医疗机构里，确实有些人可能已经接受过精神科护士之类的培训。他们接着去从事更具治疗性质的工作，而不仅仅是运用他们的护理技能，不过他们的护理背景为他们的知识打下了非常坚实的基础。我非常喜欢我们的心理学团队中有这样的人。当然，人们选择这样做可能是因为他们正在考虑更进一步的阶段。但是，CBT治疗师本身就是一个职业和资质，你完全可以选择一直留在这个岗位上，这绝对没有问题。当然，你也可以开始考虑，也许未来我想要继续深造，
from personal experience about since the pandemic, everything's changed, doesn't it? So half of my hours, or I would take up with face-to-face clients and the other half of my week I would take up with remote clients or group clients so group can be also face-to-face or remotely too so at the minute I'm doing I do four days so do two days in person two days remotely and how many kind of hours of intervention would you be doing across those four days typically so per day if you're working sort of normal hours throughout the weeks it would be four clients of four contacts per day. Great. So it's similar to when I was working in an NHS setting that I was kind of striving for 50% face-to-face or just over that. And I'm just thinking as we
根据我个人的经验，自大流行以来，一切都变了，不是吗？所以我的工作时间有一半是接待面对面的客户，而另一半时间则是接待远程客户或小组客户。小组客户也可以是面对面的，或者是远程的。所以目前我做四天，两天线下，两天远程。在这四天里，你通常会进行多少小时的干预治疗呢？如果按照正常的每周工作时间来看，每天大约是四个客户或四次接触。太棒了。这和我以前在NHS工作时的情况很像，当时我争取的是50%的面对面接触率或略多一点。我在想，在我们
speak about actually people who might choose to become CBT therapists. And certainly in services I've worked with, it was people who maybe already had training as kind of psychiatric nurses. And they kind of went on to then do something more kind of therapeutic rather than just using their nursing, but it underpinned, their nursing underpinned, kind of their knowledge really, really well. And I loved having them in our psychology team. And of course, people might be choosing to do this because they're maybe thinking about stages beyond that. But, you know, CBT therapist is, is a, is a career and a qualification in itself, and you might choose to stay there. And that's absolutely okay. But of course, you can begin to think about, well, maybe I might want to go on
谈到那些可能选择成为CBT治疗师的人。在我在其中工作过的机构里，确实有些人可能已经接受过精神科护士之类的培训。他们后来选择做一些更具治疗性质的工作，而不仅仅是发挥他们的护理技能，但他们的护理背景为他们的知识打下了非常坚实的基础。我非常喜欢他们在我们的心理学团队中。当然，人们选择这样做，可能是因为他们在考虑之后的职业阶段。但是，你知道，CBT治疗师本身就是一项职业和资格，你完全可以选择一直留在这个岗位上。这绝对没问题。当然，你也可以开始考虑，也许我想继续
and do doctorate in counselling psychology or doctorate in clinical psychology or forensic. Like there's options for career growth as well. Now of course if you're already working as a band seven going back to a band six training role or even self-funding in the case of counselling and then still coming out as a band seven is, you know, not without its limits. But people might want the more training and variety that's on offer from doing a doctorate course. And then of course it can then mean that you can build your career kind of seven and beyond with kind of a practitioner psychologist qualification. So absolutely. So the natural next step would be a senior CBT therapist. So that role involves not just doing one-to-one clinical work, but actually getting
去攻读心理咨询心理学博士学位、临床心理学博士学位或法医心理学博士学位。职业发展还有很多其他的选择。当然，如果你已经是一名七级员工，要倒退回六级的培训岗位，或者甚至在咨询心理学的情况下自费培训，最后出来依然是七级，这并非没有局限性。但人们可能希望获得博士课程所能提供的更多培训和多样性。当然，这也就意味着你可以凭借执业心理学家的资质，在七级及以上的岗位上继续构建你的职业生涯。所以完全可以这样。很自然地，下一步会是高级CBT治疗师。这个角色不仅涉及一对一的临床工作，还要实际参与医疗机构层面的事务。例如，为CBT治疗师的需求发声。比如在多学科团队（MDT）会议上进行陈述，如果某位临床心理学家说“这可能适合CBT治疗师”，那么CBT治疗师及当时的动态可能会回应说“由于X、Y、Z等原因，未必如此”。此外，还要寻找持续专业发展（CPD）的机会。所以这里确实大有可为。你还可以在医疗机构内部创建治疗方案，从而涉足管理和领导角色。你也可以继续前进。我现在正处于考虑进一步拓展自己的阶段，是的，可能会选择降一个薪级去申请博士培训，比如临床心理学培训。但话说回来，我觉得CBT培训最棒的地方在于，它真正为你打下了非常好的基础。最重要的是，它赋予了你作为临床医生的自信。这是一个非常好的起点，你会觉得：“好吧，作为一名临床医生，我对自己的认知很清晰，现在我想更多地挑战一下自己。”我认为这会让过渡到博士培训的过程变得更加顺畅。当我还是个PWP时，我曾考虑过临床心理学，但对我个人而言，我觉得跨度太大了，当时觉得自己还没准备好。老实说，我后悔走CBT培训这条路线吗？绝对不后悔。我非常高兴自己投入了那些时间。正因为我经历了那个过程，我现在感觉准备得充分多了，而且这一切都是按照我自己的意愿在进行的。
involved with the service side of things. So advocating for CBT therapists' needs, I guess. So presenting within MDT, you know, if a clinical psychologist saying, oh, this might be appropriate for CBT therapists. So CBT therapist and that dynamic might be, well, not necessarily because of X, Y, Z reasons, but also looking up for like CPD opportunities. So there's definitely you can, there is a variety that you can do, you know, you can create treatment protocols within services as well. So you can get into that role. And you can move on as well. So I'm at a point where I'm thinking about expanding myself a little bit more. And yeah, it might be going down a band and looking at
参与服务运营方面的工作。我想，也就是为CBT治疗师的需求发声。比如在多学科团队（MDT）中进行陈述，如果临床心理学家说，哦，这可能适合CBT治疗师，那么CBT治疗师和这种动态关系可能会回应说，不一定，因为这样那样的原因。同时，也要寻找持续专业发展（CPD）的机会。所以这里确实大有可为，你可以做很多不同类型的事情，你知道的，你还可以在机构内部创建治疗方案。所以你可以深入到这个角色中，并且也可以继续晋升。所以我也到了这样一个阶段，我正在考虑稍微拓展一下自己。是的，可能也会考虑调整职级并寻找
the doctorate training, clinical psychology training. But again, they're all, I think what I find with the CBT training is that actually it just gives you a really good foundation. Most of all, confidence in yourself as a clinician. It's a really good base and you're like, okay, well, I know myself as a clinician. I'd like to sort of stretch myself a little bit more now. It makes the transition so much more seamless, I think, to get into the doctorate training. I find I'd considered clinical psychology when I was a PWP, but for me personally, I felt like the leap was too much. I didn't feel ready for it. And honestly, do I regret going down the CBT training route? Absolutely not. I am so happy I'd invested that time. Because I'd done that, I feel much more ready and I'm doing it on my terms.
是的，这太有力量了，不是吗？因为事实上，无论我们处于什么阶段，我们都需要感受到自己已经准备好了，我们不希望感到不堪重负。所以，谢谢你。这是一期非常棒的节目。我想如果在YouTube上观看的人能在评论区为萨哈娜送上一波爱心就好了。你在两期节目中都做得非常出色，真正帮助我们对CBT有了切身的体会——它是什么、包含哪些内容以及它能帮助谁。非常感谢你抽出时间，萨哈娜，甚至还在你的休息日接受我们的采访。不，非常感谢邀请我。正如我所说，我们平时其实不太有机会谈论这类事情。所以能有这样一个机会……
Yeah. Oh, that's so powerful, isn't it? Because actually, yeah, like we need to feel ready, wherever we're at. we don't want to feel overwhelmed. So thank you. It's been a really lovely episode and I think let's spam the comments if people are watching on YouTube with with some love for Sahana. Like you've done a really lovely job in both episodes of really helping us get a feel for CBT, what it is, you know, what it involves and who it helps. So thank you so much for your time, Sahana and for seeing us on your day off as well. No, thank you so much for having me. Like I said, we don't, I don't really get to talk about these sorts of things. So it's just good.
我以前从来没见过类似的东西，比如去看一个视频然后了解什么是CBT培训。我当时不得不通过向其他CBT治疗师请教来做大量的底层调研。所以能有这样一个供人们参考的节目，真的太美妙了。太完美了，这正是播客的作用所在，不是吗？它让你免去了自己去调研这一切的麻烦，我们提出了大家可能都想知道的所有问题。非常感谢你抽出时间，萨哈娜。是的，我们很快再见。再次感谢我们的嘉宾萨哈娜。如果你还没看过我们关于“什么是CBT”的第一期节目，
to sort of, I've never really seen anything like this, you know, like listen to a video and what is CBT training. I had to do the groundwork of asking other CBT therapists. So it's so nice to know that there's something out there that people can sort of look at. Perfect. That's what the podcast does, isn't it? It saves you having to research all of this yourself and we ask all the questions, hopefully, that other guys would want to know. Thank you so much for your time, Sahana. And yeah, I'll see you very soon. Thank you. again to our guest Sahana. If you haven't yet caught the first episode we did on what CBT is,
去了解——我以前从未见过这样的内容，比如观看视频来了解什么是CBT培训。我当时不得不做基础工作，去向其他CBT治疗师打听。所以很高兴知道现在有这样一种资源，供大家参考。太棒了，这正是这个播客的作用，不是吗？它省去了你自己去研究所有这些事情的麻烦，我们帮你问了所有其他人可能想知道的问题。非常感谢你抽出时间，萨哈娜（Sahana）。是的，我们很快就会再见。谢谢。再次感谢我们的嘉宾萨哈娜。如果你还没看过我们关于什么是CBT的第一期节目，
please do. There will be a link in the show notes or in the YouTube description. I would love to know what you think to this episode. I would love your comments and I do always respond too. So please do drop a comment or a question on YouTube or on Spotify. You can do that too. And if you're listening on Apple Podcasts, please do rate and review the show. It really does help others to know that we are worth tuning into. If you love reading stories and learning more about people's pathways and journeys to becoming qualified psychologists
请务必去看看。节目笔记中或YouTube描述里会提供链接。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法，欢迎大家留言，我一定会回复的。所以请在YouTube或Spotify上留下你的评论或问题，你也可以在Spotify上留言。如果你是在Apple Podcasts上收听，请给节目评分并写下评论，这真的能帮助其他人了解我们值得一听。如果你喜欢阅读故事并深入了解人们成为合格心理学家
or other mental health professions, please do check out both the aspiring psychologist collective book and the clinical psychologist collective book. They both get lovely reviews and they are such illuminating, warming, inspiring reads. If you've read them already and not yet dropped us an Amazon, good reads review, please do. If you'd like to grab your free psychology success guide, head
或其他心理健康专业人员的成长路径和心路历程，请务必查看《有志心理学家合集》和《临床心理学家合集》这两本书。它们都获得了很好的评价，是非常富有启发性、温暖且鼓舞人心的读物。如果你已经读过这两本书，但还没在亚马逊或Goodreads上留下评论，请务必去写一条。如果你想获取免费的心理学成功指南，请访问
along to my website, www.uspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com.uk. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast, that's your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical
我的网站：www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk。如果你正寻找成为心理学家的道路，那就让这本书成为你的指南。有这个播客相伴，你将走上通往获得资质的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的“有志心理学家播客”。我非常享受阅读这些内容，并且很喜欢深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所经历的各种背景和经历。了解申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我如何设法绕过这些障碍，真的非常有趣。我曾一度开始怀疑自己，不知道自己是否有足够的能力去申请临床
psychology doctorate but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot so the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学博士学位，但这次经历真正给了我迈出这一步所需的信心。所以，向大家致以最诚挚的感谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。